[Music]
while the Muller investigation is
garnering all the headlines many
Republicans are asking why possible
collusion between the Clinton campaign
and Russia is being largely ignored that
comes after the Washington Post revealed
Hillary Clinton's campaign helped fund a
salacious dossier about President Trump
congressman trey Gowdy wants to know
exactly who authorized the dossiers
funding one of the areas of significance
Chris is just how hard the Democrats in
Congress fault Republicans for trying to
gain access to this information if it
were up to Adam Schiff and other
Democrats who of course want all the
facts to come out they don't want all
the facts of Russia to come out except
who financed the dossier I'm also
interested in sharing some memory tricks
with folks at the DNC because no one can
remember who paid ten million dollars to
a law firm to do Oppo research I find
that stunning ten million dollars and no
one can remember who authorized it who
approved it that's a lot of billable
hours speaking as a former attorney
joining us now for reaction is
congressman Devin Nunez the Republican
chairman of the House Intelligence look
so you look great this hour look you're
thank you thanks for being with us on
the first show okay so where are we now
on this and make it easy for our viewers
to understand and follow this where are
we today so there's a lot of moving
parts so let's start with we still have
information from fusion GPS that we
needed from the bank we still have a
whole host of information from
Department of Justice and FBI that we
hope to begin to get tomorrow so this is
we are just really at the beginning of
unraveling questions that we've been
asking since March and let me go to what
mr. gaudi's comment was there if people
really believe that the FBI did not know
who paid for that dossier I've got a
bridge to sell you there is no possible
way that the FBI did not know who paid
for that dossier and yet month after
month who's lying at the FBI who
specifically don't know if it's is it
just Comey or is it the whole FBI
and let lets let's just tell that what
you're saying about the FBI there that's
it quite a charge absolutely the
government out of control that this is
we hear about deep state we hear about
these forces Byrd and the government who
are working against the people's
interest but need to know the
transparency in government it's it is
not okay for us to ask since March who
paid for the dossier what did you use
the dossier for and then it comes out
only because of subpoenas to the bank
and the bank was gonna have to produce
the subpoenas that then all of a sudden
they cut a deal and then they could have
deal now where are we with these bank
records I read today that you you you're
in the process of getting them and did
they just willingly turn them over to my
dad we're fighting in court
cuz that's the key right saying who
where the money went specifically and
will it illustrate for what well we have
a whole bunch of questions about fusion
GPS so so there's a whole host we want
to know were they being paid by Russians
were they paying right they have Russian
clients separated right they separated
the Russian clients from the Clinton DNC
work that's what they closed so they say
but look we're investigating this yeah
we need the information we have the FBI
and other agencies who either didn't
tell us who paid for the dossier or
didn't know which would be equally
disturbing but my guess is somebody over
there knew who paid for similar resign
as special prosecutor given potential
conflicts of interest regarding
something that may in fact be Russian
collusion during the campaign it was FBI
director correct we are number one I'm
very concerned about it okay but let's
see today he had these initial
indictments I think you cover on the
show earlier the right way which is
there's nothing there let's see where he
goes from here if this continues to drag
on and on and on then we're going to
have a problem because right now what I
see is is we have fusion GPS obstructing
the investigation the Democrats
obstructing our investigation and the
government the executive branch
obstructing our investigation could
Obama have known about this well he was
briefed on the dossier in January do you
believe he didn't know anything about it
before then why would he but this was 10
ten million dollars paid to Perkins Kui
law firm that then funneled it to fusion
gps why didn't the payment go that way
why did it go to the law firm law firm
diffusion Fusion to Christopher steel
who got the information from Russia to
cover it to cover the tracks right to
cover the tracks and I think it's hard
to believe that when when President
Obama was being briefed on this dossier
that all of his intelligence people the
best intelligence agencies in the world
had no idea who paid for that
information Adam Schiff your Democrat
counterpart has said that you have
become
you have become an obstacle to the Trump
Russia collusion investigation because
you know you were stepped aside and then
you didn't step aside can you clear that
up for us because that's confusing to
people people thank you recuse yourself
there's a lot of crazy things that that
the media the mainstream media says
about me and others but the bottom line
is this we we are being obstructed in
this investigation we have for a long
time there's no question that I was
attacked viciously by the left you were
well aware of it
to try to get me off this and they were
trying to intimidate you from speaking
out which is what they do to a lot of
people do they not that's what they did
yeah I mean remember it was all over me
originally going to the White House
saying that that you looked at these
documents I looked at documents yeah I'm
asking where Trump administration
officials had been unmasked right some
of those ended up in the media this is a
major problem with leaks from our
intelligence yeah deep state's leak and
lately can really gonna make you look
bad and are you gonna bring back Susan
Rice and these others to testify we are
gonna have two powers actually we're
gonna bring back a lot of people well
let's hope they explore the DOJ could do
their job and begin to investigate this
I'm not thinking about mother's gonna
rush to that but maybe maybe I'm just
being pessimistic
thank you very much congressman
graduation saying yourself